und jetzt begrüßen wir einen der beiden
bundesvorsitzenden von bündnis 90 die
grünen die bild nannte ihn einen 90
zitiere wörtlich frauenschwarm dazu
fällt mir ein dass es durchaus ein
gesellschaftlicher fortschritt dass
inzwischen auch männer auf ihr äußeres
reduziert werden hier ist robert habeck
willkommen wie bisher
so
herbert schön dass sie da sind
glückwunsch zum höhenflug bayern hessen
kann man es rund um die uhr genießen
oder hat man im hinterkopf brauche immer
noch diese ich glaube 8,9 prozent von
der bundestagswahl letztes jahr und
denkt man kann dem wähler dieser
launischen bratze nicht trauen
man kann nach vorne schauen und geht ja
immer weiter was gut was passiert ist
dass wir nicht nur mehr über die afg
reden sondern mir schon manchmal das
auch das ist auch cool aber wir reden
auch wieder über andere themen was das
beste geht also gar nicht so sehr um die
grünen sondern geht darum dass das land
wieder ein bisschen mehr ein bisschen
mehr das kurs hat als über nur nach
rechts hinten zu schauen das richtig
verstanden er erfolg hat gar nichts mit
den grünen zu tun
naja aber die grünen haben ein bisschen
dazu beigetragen dass wir nicht mehr nur
mit den aktien billig stärker hinten
rechts im bundestag gucken das schon
ganz cool ist denn der erfolg so groß
weil die grünen gerade so gut sind oder
weil der wähler aktuell die anderen
parteien einfach schlimmer findet
natürlich genau verstanden
naja es gibt ja es gibt ja leute die
sagen ihr seid so ein bisschen das große
frust auffangbecken für alle die zum
beispiel die af.de niemals wählen würden
naja dass die große koalition das gute
jahre hatte das war keiner sagen und wir
haben ein paar sachen nicht falsch
gemacht würde ich mir denken und
zusammen gibt es dann eine art
vertrauensvorschuss für uns jetzt
dringend die grünen ja gerade in
bürgerliche milieus vor in denen nie
zuvor ein grüner gewesen ist in bayern
zum beispiel haben viele leute zum
ersten mal in ihrem leben die grünen
gewählt weil wir wissen ja die haben
einfach gemerkt hey das sind nicht mehr
die grünen meiner jugend die waschen
sich
zum beispiel sind alles alte klischee
aber
was ich ja eigentlich was ich eigentlich
spannend finde diese milieus die jetzt
dazu kommen wie verändern die wiederum
die grünen macht das die grünen
bürgerliche oder politisch formuliert
ich weiß diesen schriftsteller sind die
grünen noch rock'n'roll oder schon
bausparvertrag an dieser formulierung
habe ich über eine woche gefeiert
wir stimmen in die polen sich nicht
verändern würden also das problem der
anderen parteien ist er vielleicht dass
sie sich zu wenig verändern
und insofern ist das jetzt kein nicht
zur verfügung sich schämen muss das neue
leute mit eigenen und neuen ideen dazu
kommen wir sind ja ganz gut und wenn die
ein bausparvertrag mitbringen zu wort
also das ist es so ich finds ja gut wenn
man sagt wir wollen jetzt weniger nische
wir wollen mehr mitte seien aber für
mainstream zahlt man hat ihren preis das
heißt wie bei bands sagt man immer ich
fand die besser als die noch keiner
kannte ihn nicht
ich glaube das ist auch nicht das
gleiche wie wir bringen im bahnsport
bausparvertrag mit sondern die leute
suchen eine politik die radikale
antworten gibt die zu der radikalität
der wirklichkeit passen und das ist eine
suchbewegung die es gibt und deswegen
war das völlig falsch wenn wir glauben
würden gewählt werden oder wir lassen
uns einreden dass wir jetzt im lauwarmen
werden müssen wenn man es genau
andersrum
wir reden ein bisschen mehr mit den
leuten und nicht zu den leuten also
nicht so diese überhebliche gestus die
uns manchmal nachgesagt wurde und auch
zurecht ehrlicherweise aber in den in
den inhalten wollen wir keine abstriche
machen ganz im gegenteil und das glaube
ich ist auch das was die menschen spüren
man kann nicht die ganze zeit über den
klimawandel reden wie das gefährlich ist
und die menschheitsaufgabe und was tut
man nicht das check doch jeder dass das
gar keine politik ist eigentlich und
deswegen glaube ich dass was sie gerade
als zweites gesagt haben auf erstarrten
bausparvertrag alles cool aber nicht in
den inhalten abrüsten sondern er
radikaler werden weil nur das
realistisch ist ich wollte jetzt auch
nicht darüber
ja
ich hab mir ich habe mir zur
vorbereitung auf heute abend natürlich
ein paar interviews mit ihnen angeguckt
und mir fällt auf serie gehen immer so
ein bisschen zickig wenn man sagt die
grünen haben reiche wähler was haben sie
denn gegen leistungsträger her habe ich
mich gar nichts stimmt doch gar nicht
wir bedienen uns aus allen ein bisschen
gucken einfach namen wie die fragen sind
und wir unser das einkaufs spektrum der
grünen ist so wie bei der spd
beispielsweise gesagt dass das was gut
ist das ist einfach es ist einfach so
was intended hat so ist ist dass mehr
jüngere leute uns häufig wählen und die
jüngeren leute sind häufig erwarten
gesellschaftlicher fortschritt da können
wir gar nichts dafür gut gebildet also
das bildungsniveau in deutschland steigt
dann irgendwann koaliert das auch mit
einkommen aber das ist auch alles
es ist nicht so dass die damit ich
verbirgt sich ein vorwurf die millionäre
in denen die grünen und die grünen muss
man sich leisten können und so ist es
nicht passen wir fassen ja permanent
beschlüsse gegen die interessen unserer
wähler und wählerinnen also flugbenzin
soll besteuert werden und eine höhere
einkommensteuer und vermögen besteuern
und so weiter und deswegen würde ich
diesen vorwurf da nicht drin haben ihr
seid beliebig oder ihr werdet beliebig
werden leute aus verschiedenen
einkaufszentren segment euch wählen so
lustigen würde ich nicht sagen aber
weise daran gefunden nein ich korrigiere
was falsch ist und es ist ja auch fakt
dass es nicht in allen milieus gleich
gut läuft logischerweise wenn man sieht
wo es noch nicht so dollar für die grüne
grünen sind die arbeiter zum beispiel so
war es in bayern und in hessen zumindest
auf dem land läuft schlecht als in der
stadt und im osten müssen wir froh sein
wenn ich mit steinen beworfen werdet
also
aber wer auf dem weg zur volkspartei ist
schon auch noch arbeit schön dass sie ja
sagen sonst werde ich immer nur gefragt
wollt ihr eine volkspartei sein oder
seid ihr eine sind wir nicht auch weil
volkspartei glaube ich die falsche
antwort ist jetzt auf die probleme der
zeit erstmal heißt volkspartei ja alles
wird miteinander schon in der partei und
gemauschelt und eben habe ich noch mal
versucht zu argumentieren dass radikale
herausforderung hat die kahle antworten
brauchen insofern ist das auch die
falsche laufrichtung aber ja
ostdeutschland ist eine echte
herausforderung für uns aber für alle
parteien
mein eindruck ist die neuen
erfolgreicheren grünen sind aber auch
einen tick um konkreter geworden als
früher
beispiel die grünen sind weiter für
soziale gerechtigkeit im prinzip weiß
auch eine feine sache ist aber ich
behaupte
ihr würdet euch nicht nochmal einen
steuererhöhungs wahlkampf 2013 trauen
oder irre ich mich
naja im wahlprogramm stand der letzten
bundestagswahl das noch alles drin ein
bisschen abgeschwächt habe dann in
jamaika ist wann hast du es war nur
nicht konkret genug weil dann auf die
frage wie hoch soll die vermögenssteuer
sein oder wer soll vermögenssteuer
zahlen die antwort gegeben wurden die
den rolex tragen und das natürlich ein
scheiß antwortet ich das mal sagen also
ehrlich gesagt für höhere steuern für
superreiche ohne zu sagen aber man
hintritt superreiche es macht keinen
sinn genau das gebe ich gerne zu das ist
nicht sehr konkret gewesen aber noch
einmal wir fangen ja in gewissem sinne
jetzt erst noch mal neu an und das soll
gerne konkreter werden und umgekehrt bei
anderen punkten
die sicherlich jetzt auch kandidierende
cdu leute interessieren werden comics
geschäfte das sind diese steuerbetrugs
geschichten die große banken miteinander
machen oder das große
immobiliengesellschaften keine steuern
zahlen deswegen ihre wohnung hin und her
tauschen können und jedes mal beim
tauschen mieterhöhung machen
da sind ja sehr konkret und sehr
spezifisch haben anträge im bundestag
und bundesrat in europa laufen also es
gibt nicht den schatten aber so gut ich
gestaltungswille finden und regieren
wollte im gegensatz zu anderen parteien
es war ja schon auffällig dass die
grünen schon in den aller ersten jamaika
gesprächen diese gerade erwähnte
vermögenssteuer quasi zurück genommen
haben
ihr habt dann in den im verlauf der
gespräche auch auf eure ausstiegsdaten
für
kohle für verbrennungsmotor verzichtet
mein gefühl war entschuldigung wenn die
gespräche jetzt noch eine woche
weitergehen dann macht er zur not selber
die atomkraftwerke wieder an
das problem ist nur bei den nächsten
jamaica gesprächen wird die union denken
das sei ja alles schon so verhandelt
erstmal gibt es keine nächsten gespräche
jeweils ja nie wie ich komme ja aus
jamaika koalition aus schleswig-holstein
das kann auch funktionieren aber nur
wenn alle einen schritt weiter
aufeinander zu geben gehen richtig ist
wir haben damals die enddaten bei ihm
verkehr beim dieselmotor aufgegeben aber
konkrete schritte vereinbart beim
kohleausstieg was genau andersrum und
richtig ist aber auch wir waren bis zur
schmerzgrenze kompromissbereit und wir
hätten nicht gewusst wenn das wenn nicht
gegangen wäre ob parteitag gekriegt
hätten manche ist das schon etwas zu
verkaufen wäre es schwer geworden in der
tat und so weit haben wir uns gequält
und das ist völlig richtig dass wir
verständnis da reingegangen sind das
nicht noch mal große koalition jetzt
kommen sollte und das hat uns viel
zugemutet mehr als wir eigentlich tragen
hätten können vielleicht aber aus einer
gesellschaftlichen verantwortung heraus
und das sage ich jetzt ein bisschen mit
pathos aber es stimmt ja auch irgendwie
jetzt zerbricht unser zerbröselt uns das
parteiensystem wie wir es kannten hätten
sich ein paar mehr leute vielleicht auch
mehr kompromisse zu müssen
da war mehr auf einem da ging es um mehr
als eine eigentliche parteiprogramm
programmatik sondern da ging es
tatsächlich und das wusste man
eigentlich wenn man den kopf an gemacht
hat um eine lebendige demokratie in
deutschland und da haben wir ja keine
haare mehr demokratie haben sich damals
daten ja die snc die müssen vorkommen
ist es nur nicht richtig wenn eine
partei alle kompromisse machen müssen
die anderen stehen da und sagen
hauptsache wir wir bleiben bei uns
selbst das war natürlich elend insofern
war das problem nicht dass wir zu viele
kompromisse bereit waren zu machen
sondern die anderen erst zu wenig da
keine ehrlich sie haben philosophie
theologie und germanistik studiert ist
das denn das sind normalerweise drei top
voraussetzungen für den taxischein
und ich weiß nicht
nicht
[Applaus]
so
aber es stattdessen sind sie heute
berufspolitiker sie waren vor dem grünen
vorsitz von sechs jahre minister in
schleswig holstein und gelten trotzdem
als frischer unverbrauchter
quereinsteiger wie geht das denn ich
habe sie ja auch nicht lieber sagen dass
wir nicht mitkriegen was in
schleswig-holstein passiert auf dieser
wiese da oben oder wann wir euch das
hängt von der optik aber es stimmt schon
also ich behaupte dass nicht von mir ich
bin seither berufspolitiker und habe
meine schlachten geschlagen und sachen
gewonnen und verloren und diese ist
irgendwie in kinder gar nicht mehr kommt
von außen ist ja nicht mein problem also
ich mache es mir das nicht an zu sagen
wichtig ist aber auch dass philosophie
studieren erstmal brotlose kunst ist was
war das geile damals man wollte was
brotlose machen ich wollte ihnen fällst
du nichts machen von dem ich wusste wenn
du das machst dann kannst du danach den
bausparvertrag sondern da wollte ich das
leben einmal fordern ganz zum schluss so
schön es ist dass es bei euch gerade
läuft diese sendung setzt sich immer für
die schwächsten ein lasst uns noch ganz
kurz über die spd reden haben sie haben
sie gar kein schlechtes gewissen im
moment so als aktiver sterbehilfe der
sozialdemokratie
[Musik]
ein schlechtes gewissen habe ich nicht
aber mitleid und das ist noch viel
elender eigentlich verloren die nicht
glaube ich genau wenn du mit einem
politiker hast dann ist es die
höchststrafe eigentlich also ist schon
schwer glaube ich im moment
sozialdemokrat zu sein und dass ich
meine die haben auch wahlkampf gemacht
und die ganzen mitglieder sind da von
tür zu tür getingelt und haben ihre
flyer verteilt und ihren sport
vernachlässigt um die katze nicht
gefüttert das war auch alles demokratie
und und kriegt nix dafür also es ist
schon hart naja also mal dass das linke
lager wie es früher kannten sich gerade
so ein bisschen kannibalisiert
schlussfrage freuen sich eigentlich
schon auf die nächsten jamaika fahren
mit kanzler märz oder hält sich die
vorfreude in grenzen mal abwarten was
nun passiert am sinn favoriten bei den
drei thronfolge ja aber das sage ich
nicht aber die favoriten ist sowie keine
ahnung bayern münchen hsv und was ich
noch sagen frankfurt ok möge der beste
gewinnen würdest du dann geht die post
ab
ich sag mal so wenn es märz wird dann
passt der koalitionsvertrag in jedem
fall auf einem bierdeckel robert habeck
meine damen und herren stehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]